we're gonna get this one started with
the guys you see on the screen in front
of you including taylor clark today's
starting pitcher presented by nissan 27
year old right hander a solid outing
last monday when he had to step in and
make a start at the very last minute
filling in for the injured merrill kelly
and when you say here's dickerson
dickerson
two for nine in the series
and dickerson it's a high drive to right
looking up calhoun
out of here
and it's one nothing giants your giant
starter his eighth start this year last
one a bit of a bumpy ride six earned
runs allowed in four innings against the
dodgers there's a high pop up to left
field
and that's gonna end the inning lead off
walk does not hurt johnny cueto second
inning coming up it'll be solano it's
one nothing giants
[Music]
that one goes by belt solano out there
makes a nice play but escobar
is safe at first
a little tweeter there for eduardo it's
a one-ounce lead
marshall sits up outside
fastball anthony's five strikeouts for
taylor clark see what he's got for the
panda on a ball and two strikes
waves at a change up
and he gets his sixth strikeout
one-nothing giants on a first-inning
home run here's the 2-2 marte strikes
out swinging and he's talking to himself
and looking at cueto as he walks back
toward the
dugout third straight strikeout for
cueto that was another
shimmy twist move
double clutched him and he got him for
his fourth strikeout in a row
it's all about rhythm with johnny cueto
and he's in a good one right now
[Applause]
and taylor clark puts him away with a
slider and he has matched his career
high with seven strikeouts good pitch in
a good location with two strikes duban
in swing mode just trying to foul
everything off and taylor got nice
downward movement on that hard slider
see that ball breaks almost straight
down
he has looked very good today as good as
we've seen taylor all year
high fly ball drifting into left center
for starlight martine
taylor clark looking good he's giving up
only one hit
here's the two and two pitch after the
shimmy
strike three called with a changeup on
the outside and
lamb is very unhappy with that call
three up three down cueto has retired 11
in a row since he allowed his only hit
of the game in the second event
and a shot to right that's a base hit
marshall turns second he'll hang on
there as yustromski gets it back in a
hurry
and the divebacks have their second hit
first and second one out
got him
with a changeup
six strikeouts
seventh inning coming up
one pitch one out to start the seventh
for that one here's escobar
live all right field escobar carries it
out of here
and juardo escobar over the wall in
right for a home run and we are tied up
at one there's grant trenboth's crew
number four for escobar it's a 1-1 ball
game
baby left partner
crawford lines it the other way and it's
going to be a base hit
and peralta did a good job of keeping
that ball from going by him this is
lined on the left field line that's a
fair ball
crawford's on the move and what are they
going to do they're going to
hold them up at third
wilmer flores coming through with a
pinch hit doubles and now the bases are
loaded for dickerson
for the 1-0 pinch
swing line drive base head left field
crawford is in the score
rickard goes to third he'll stop there
the ball was fielded in shallow left and
alex dickerson has put the giants ahead
for the second time today
this time with an rbi single
bounces this one and it's in the center
field of base hit yashrimsky's going to
score from second and longoria has done
it again with that open right side he
bounces one through so a four to one
lead
vanderbilt shoots this one up the middle
and he's got a base hit he's been using
the middle of the diamond a lot he
always manages to sneak one in there
doesn't he third fourth and fifth place
hitters coming up starling marty peralta
and then walker
there's a ball off the fish falling into
shallow right field and it's in there
base hit pablo to second he'll stop
there
so duvan got one on the hands
but kind of
blooped it out into shallow right where
calhoun did not have a chance to come
catch it here's the pitch bounce to the
right side out in shallow right field
solano's got it he slings it over to
first
in time and the ball game is over
three ground ball outs
induced
from the three four five spots in the
arizona batting order some of their best
hitters
and sam coonrod gets his first major
league save
he'd had only three in his minor league
career
and
the giants have taken the series and
it's the first time the giants have won
a series on the road
in 2020